jennifer aniston and justin theroux
split what went wrong plus Captain
America doesn't have black panther
tickets but we got a pair of tickets to
now horn and Maren Morris to give away
guys a not so happy Friday Jen Aniston
and Justin Theroux announced late
Thursday it's over and forgive me for
the dramatics but will Jen ever find her
Lobster
more importantly do you think she'll go
back to Brad Pitt most of the internet
seems to think so
one fan tweeted somewhere Jennifer
Aniston is cracking her hey let's grab
coffee you catch up text a Brad Pitt one
thing we do know Jen and Justin told et
in a statement their separation was a
mutual decision and they remain best
friends but apparently the split was
actually a long time coming
a source tells et the major issue was
location Justin loves New York and Jenn
it's comfortable in LA as am I quote
Jen's a homebody
she likes hosting friends and staying in
mi Jen Aniston all right the other major
factor paparazzi source tells et Jen was
constantly hounded by photographers in
New York so much so it became an issue
at home in their West Village apartment
it even angered the neighbors according
to the source the final straw for Jen
came when Justin's motorcycle was
vandalized covered in baloney Jen
assumed an angry neighbor did it the
source explained quote she just never
really could get settled in she wasn't
happy in New York City but yes it is
hard to ignore that Jennifer and her
one-time loved Brad Pitt are now both
single but a source tells et that they
are absolutely not together however as
the source put it you can't predict the
future let's also keep in mind Brad
isn't officially divorced from Angelina
so cool your jets huh how's that for
some tea speaking of let's grab a cup
now with lauren zima to talk british
royalty
yes Thank You Daniel you know if you
guys love all the dirt on celebrity
couples that Danny brings you
I'm going to be spilling the royalty as
we count down to the Royal Wedding you
did there each week on YouTube we are
diving deep into Megan Markos future as
Prince Harry's wife gonna give you guys
everything you need to know about the
biggest wedding in modern history it's
every Friday on et's YouTube channel we
are spilling the royalty Cheerios who
are you a shameless plug actually I
should watch it's really fun alright
move it on to the hottest ticket in
Hollywood I'm talking about Black
Panther which just hit theaters the film
has been getting rave reviews and has
already made get this over 25 million
dollars just from Thursday showings in
the u.s. this is the second best
Thursday showing for a Marvel movie
after Avengers age of Ultron
we actually just caught up with Avengers
star Chris Evans who plays Captain
America and he says he can't wait to see
it
I was just watching some stuff last
night about it I mean it is it is
powerful Brian just said he saw the
other night I can't wait to go see it
I'm gonna wait for the dice down a
little bit Chadwicks a good buddy I mean
he's so fantastic and from what I've
heard we've seen the film he really
knocks it big weekend for the movies and
new music it's Friday and you guys know
what that means
let's talk new stuff in the music world
Drake dropped the new video for his
track God's plan and with a budget of
nearly 1 million dollars they gave it
all away
I don't wanna die for them to miss me
yes I see the things that they wish you
know me hope I got some brothers that I
live me they gonna tell a story she was
friendly me guys playing guys playing
now while Drake is making it rain bills
ellie goulding is making my eyeballs
rain with this hauntingly beautiful
cover of Vincent starry starry night
flaming flowers now brightly blaze
swirling clouds and violent haze reflect
in Vincents eyes of China blue colors
changing
morning fields of amber grain weathered
faces lined in pain are soothed beneath
the artist loving hand I feel like
crawling into a ball of my feelings okay
but wait we do have to end on a high
note though in it doesn't get more lit
than Sean Paul David Guetta and Becky
G's new collab mad love
[Music]
so those are our new music Friday picks
of the week but that one enough we got a
little surprise for you guys
ET online is giving away a pair of
tickets and soundcheck passes to the
Niall Horan and Marin Maura's tour in
the u.s. city of your choice all you
have to do is visit ET online.com slash
giveaway to see a complete list of rules
and officially enter by midnight Friday
February 23rd and that's it guys ET
online comm slash giveaways alright
thanks so much for watching this week we
are off on Monday but we'll see you on
Tuesday so go enjoy your weekend
listening a mad love maybe little Sean
Paul